donc là on est au bike park du maïdo qui
se situe sur la route forestière
direction il est à l'acide à peu près à
face et à 1300 niveau aptitude à 30
minutes de saint paul ce lieu est un
site de pratique pour le vtt dans son
ensemble vtt descente cross country ou
enduro
aussi on peut faire un peu de trial il
ya
de quoi faire et c'est vraiment pour
progresser sur toutes les techniques du
vtt quasiment tout le monde s'est monté
à vélo mais faire du vélo après bien se
débrouiller
c'est différent et ça s'apprend
c'est bien pour apprendre les bases du
vtt de descente même pour se
perfectionner dans la discipline et pour
apprendre à sauter les gros saut il ya
des aussi des petits sauts
il faudrait vraiment essayé ça une fois
dans sa vie et moi j'ai essayé une fois
grâce à mes parents et bien ça m'a
vraiment aidé donc maintenant je me
développe petit à petit dans ce sport
des jeux voulu vite
bas il ya aussi deux langues de
l'entretien du site on équipe et un de
pelles pioches et serra
débroussailleuses et là aujourd'hui par
exemple en train de ranger les rubalises
qu'ils avaient sur une compétition et je
les prépare pour la prochaine cet
investissement public a vraiment
un sens parce que savoir que le maïdo
c'est une terre de vtt l'ofs déroule la
plus grande descente du monde dames et
la mégavalanche il ya plus de 65 km de
pistes balisées
à l'époque et plus de 1000 sur sur toute
la réunion c'est géré par le département
bien sûr le nf le parc national et comme
quelqu'un qui fait d'eux de l'athlétisme
il a besoin d'avoir un lieu
d'entraînement un stade et ben nous on a
notre stade de vtt pour pour s'améliorer
et pratiquer le vélo en toute sécurité
pour conclure je vous invite à venir au
maïdo bike park du maïdo le mercredi et
samedi c'est totalement gratuit je suis
là pour donner des conseils et en plus
regardées comme c'est beau